conférence de presse ce matin à propos
de la faire aurore mais celle là serait
l'ultime conférence c'est en tout cas ce
que nous affirme le bâtonnier hauteville
avec la nouvelle affectation de l'ancien
directeur du lycée agricole de quoi
vivent à la sphère orange est terminée
entre temps on a trouvé un poste pour
jour qui correspond à son gras filet
pour aurait nommé en guadeloupe
il est délégué du préfet chargé de la
cohésion des territoires
pour obtenir cette affectation son
avocat a dû batailler ferme face au
ministère de l'agriculture qui l'avait
nommé en août 2010 8 dans le calvados et
en normandie
alors que deux mois plus tôt le tribunal
administratif de bastia exigeait qu'elle
retrouve son poste au lycée de quoi
rivail en martinique
j'ai comme unique vidéo je vous préviens
que j'exige l'exécution intégrale du
jugement du tribunal administratif que
toute décision tout aux décisions nous
avons fait là l'objet d'un recours il
nous irons jusqu'au bout la sphère or à
débuter en 2016 suite à une mutation
avant la fin de son contrat du lycée de
quoi rivail s'ensuivra une mobilisation
des mouvements politiques des
syndicalistes d'élus qui ont protesté
contre cette mutation juge et arbitre et
après deux années de mobilisation
philippe laurent ne sera pas muté en
france et il se demande pourquoi il a
été victime de tant d'acharnement et
aucun élément objectif et ça c'est pour
moi une grande question of clowns
éléments objectifs ont pu citer que ce
soient les résultats financiers les
résultats aux examens le manège n'a rien
donc je veux savoir
je ne sais pas philippe aurore a tenu à
remercier les élus les parties les
mouvements tous les syndicalistes qui
ont pris sa défense
et c'est donc la fin de cette affaire
philippe aurore il est désormais en
poste à la préfecture de guadeloupe